a demonstration calling for justice
outside the Tokyo District Court inside
these walls judges are deciding whether
the operator of the Fukushima nuclear
plant is responsible for health problems
that may have been caused when its plant
was damaged in 2011.
diagnosed with thyroid cancer after the
Fukushima nuclear accident in 2011. we
are convinced of the causal relationship
between the two we're waiting for a
final verdict from the judge
the plaintiffs were aged between 6 and
16 at the time of the disaster and were
diagnosed with thyroid cancer between
2012 and 2018.
they all have severe symptoms
offered a great deal while receiving 3
their lives have been upended
dramatically
Japanese government has in the past
refused to link exposure to radiation
from the accident to Children developing
cancers
the plant's operator the Tokyo Electric
Power Company or tepco stands accused of
trying to escape accountability
tepco is attempting to get the victims
to drop their low suits by covering up
the truth and refusing to admit it the
incident of thyroid cancer has increased
dramatically since the Fukushima
accident the petitioners are seeking
financial compensation of nearly 700 000
each from the plant operator the court
is yet to rule on what is the first
Fukushima linked Health lawsuit since
the disaster Mike level Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera